sexta jornada en esta asamblea general
número 77 hoy hemos escuchado al líder
de la diplomacia china quien ha dicho
que nos encontramos en un momento de
profundo cambio unos cambios que están
yendo mucho más rápido de lo esperado
todo en un discurso bastante ambiguo
mucho más de lo que escuchamos en el
Consejo de Seguridad por parte de China
entonces allí abocó intensamente por un
diálogo hoy su discurso como digo ha
sido mucho más ambiguo ha dicho que
ningún país debería utilizar su fuerza
para acabar para derrotar a otro ha
dicho que quien empieza una guerra acaba
quemándose fácilmente muy interesante
también ha sido el discurso del ministro
de exteriores rusos sergey labroz quien
ha dicho Quién ha atacado directamente a
Estados Unidos y a sus aliados ha dicho
que Washington quiere convertir a todo
el mundo en su patio trasero y también
hecho hincapié en que la rusofobia de
occidente no tiene precedentes dice que
lo único que quiere es acabar con Rusia
en el mapa geopolítico interesante
también lo que no ha mencionado la broad
durante su discurso no ha hecho ningún
tipo de referencia a las amenazas
nucleares de su presidente de esta
semana tampoco ha hecho referencia a ese
proceso de reclutamiento de más de
300.000 hombres a la desesperada a lo
largo del día de hoy Seguiremos
escuchando a otros líderes mundiales
representantes de otros países como por
ejemplo hoy que hablará esta tarde el
representante de Venezuela